[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія, давайте
почнемо, ми продовжимо розмову про школу
та освіту,
тож давайте переглянемо назви кімнат,
і ми переглянемо
картинки, тому  подивіться на малюнок і
вгадайте кімнату, давайте почнемо номер один, щоб
ви могли побачити, як кілька дітей сидять на
своїх стільцях, і я не бачу жодного столу, я
не бачу книг, але я бачу багато
панелей з картинками,
тому учні малюють що  ми називаємо
цю кімнату
добре урок мистецтво і ми називаємо кімнату
мистецька студія давайте запишемо це слово
мистецька студія давайте продовжимо дивитися на цю
картинку
що це я бачу різні столи,
вони не парти насправді я також бачу
деякі комп'ютери  і я бачу
багато різних книг, тому це не
схоже на клас, що це за Браво,
це бібліотека, давайте запишемо
добре, готово, давайте подивимося на цю картинку,
це дуже цікава кімната, я
бачу багато різних змішувачів для пляшок
багато кол  або так, це коло, давайте
запишемо, щоб ви могли це бути хімічна лабораторія
чи, можливо, фізична лабораторія, що ви
думаєте, Браво, це хімічна лабораторія,
давайте перейдемо до цього класу.
Я бачу парти та багато комп’ютерів,
тому це  комп'ютерний клас, давайте
запишемо комп'ютерний клас, давайте йти далі. У мене є
для вас більше фотографій, а що щодо цієї
кімнати, це не клас, насправді я
не бачу жодних столів, парт, але я
бачу багато стільців, і, ймовірно, якщо ви
розширите картинку, ви можете  подивіться також
сцену, так що
це за актова зала Браво, це актова зала, давайте запишемо
активіст актової зали Аллах, давайте далі, а що щодо
цієї кімнати, це не актова зала, але
я бачу багато музичних інструментів,
тож це, мабуть, музична студія, так що
давайте  запишіть музичну студію, коли я
був студентом, у моїй музичній студії у нас було тільки
фортепіано, і ми могли грати на фортепіано
на уроках, ось і все, але тут я
бачу барабани, тому я думаю, що це
цікавіше, давайте перейдемо до ще одного
картинка подивіться на цю кімнату, насправді вона величезна,
судячи з вікон,
це двоповерхова кімната, то що це,
це дірка прямо в отворі, добре, іноді
це можна назвати коридором, але
коридор має форму прямокутника,
це мені здається  квадрат або
трубку, ви можете вибрати це, щоб це була діра,
і ви могли бачити головний вхід до
школи, тому подивіться, скільки слів
ви можете побачити сім Браво, і
вам буде завдання, щоб написати
диктант, і цього разу знову
буде диктант для вгадування, коли ми
вже грали в це, тому у нас є сім
слів, готових для вас на дошці, і я
збираюся рахувати від одного до п'яти, поки
я рахую, ви оберіть одне слово і
напишіть  коли я скажу п'ять,
я покажу тобі своє слово, і якщо ти вгадаєш мої
слова, то отримаєш одне очко, тож
твоє завдання насправді полягає в тому, щоб вгадати моє слово,
давайте спробуємо ще раз,
я вважаю, що ви пишете одне  слово
окей зі списку,
давайте спробуємо,
тож давайте один два три чотири  п'ять
моє слово - це все добре, що було твоє слово,
якщо у тебе також є цілий, ти набрав один
бал добре, давайте перейдемо далі один два
три чотири п'ять так що ваше слово, моє
слово - музична студія, якщо у вас також є
музична студія, один бал отримуєте для вас добре
давайте спробуємо ще раз, хм,
я виберу щось
цікаве, тож давайте один два три
чотири п'ять, що ваше слово це
комп'ютерний клас
моє слово лабораторія це дуже коротке слово,
лише три літери, якщо у вас також є лабораторія,
одна точка для вас як  добре, давайте спробуємо
ще раз добре,
один два три чотири п'ять, що у вас є
у вас є художня студія, чи є у вас мистецька студія, якщо так, будь ласка,
поставте один бал добре, а в останній
раз давайте спробуємо гмм добре, я
вибрав слова один два три  чотири п'ять
що там у
мене є бібліотека чи є у вас бібліотека якщо
так один бал, зараз порахуйте всі
бали, якщо ви вгадали всі мої слова, ви
повинні мати 5 балів, якщо ні, ймовірно, 2/3
або 1, ви також можете мати 0 це  добре, ви
можете спробувати пізніше і записати більше слів
давайте  рухаймося далі, тож давайте подивимося на цю
картинку, це не кімната
, а школа, тож тепер ми бачимо
дуже кольорове зображення, тому ми бачимо багато
кольорів, я бачу жовтий червоний синій зелений,
мені це здається заднім двором
школи, це не те  головний вхід,
тому що я бачу ці підбори
спереду, тому, ймовірно, це ззаду, і
якщо ви проаналізуєте школу, що це за
форма, це круг, ні, це
у формі трикутника, ні, це не
схоже, що це  прямокутний праворуч
або схожий на квадрат, мабуть, так
однозначно класична будівля, давайте
порахуємо, скільки тут поверхів, ви
вгадаєте, подивіться, я бачу тут кілька сходів, щоб
я міг порахувати, що це, мабуть,
триповерхова будівля, і це дуже
Мортон, це  не звичайний і
типовий, побудований у нашій школі, він дуже
сучасний,
тому давайте заглянемо всередину, а для цього давайте
прочитаємо текст, я даю вам одну хвилину, щоб
переглянути текст
добре, давайте прочитаємо разом, тому це
дуже сучасна будівля, розроблена
міжнародною компанією  l архітектори бачать, ось чому
я сказав вам, що це не схоже на
типову будівлю, тому що
задіяні міжнародні архітектори, давайте рухатися
далі. Школа має спокійну зелену зону
на нашій приватній ландшафтній території, тому
пам’ятайте ці п’яти, які ми можемо назвати
зеленими зонами або ландшафтними ділянками  давайте
перейдемо до речення про харчування, щоб
харчування було важливим для студентів, яких я
знаю, настільки поживне, збалансоване та
здорове харчування, ці школи пропонують
вам дуже смачне харчування, давайте з
обладнанням, високотехнологічним обладнанням, таким як
інтерактивні дошки, у кожній
класній кімнаті індивідуальні планшети  для кожного
учня це чудово, тому тут, у моєму
класі, у мене також є інтерактивна
дошка. У мене є це слово, це
також біле, і ми називаємо його
дошкою або чатом, прямо це дошка для
письма з маркерами, які ми не використовуємо
шматок крейди з цією дошкою, тільки маркери,
спеціально розроблені маркери для
дошки, але цей інтерактивний,
тому я можу натискати кнопки тут, я бачу, що
Відображення проектора, тому
це високотехнологічне обладнання, давайте
перейдемо до окремих планшетів для своїх
учнів, це також чудово, тому мені не
потрібно носити власний планшет, я можу мати
його в школі фантастично,
давайте перейдемо до розмови про вигляд стадіону
школа має футбольний стадіон,
баскетбольний майданчик,
сучасний GM, а також критий плавальний басейн, який
займається танцювальною музикою, поезією та
мистецтвом, це дивовижно, тому можна зробити багато
заходів, давайте подивимося
ще раз на футбольний стадіон, тож, ймовірно, це
можна використовувати для уроків фізкультури правильного
баскетболу  корти можна використовувати для
деяких уроків фізкультури, але в основному як
дозвілля, мрія сучасності про
танці, а також басейн для
занять фізкультурою. Я бачу багато студій
для танців для музики, для віршів для мистецтва,
це чудово, і, ймовірно, ці  є
додатковими заняттями або можуть бути частиною
навчальної програми, чому б не поглянути на
слово поезія чи можете ви здогадатися, що
воно означає поезія слово поет означає
маленький портвейн,
як миска, зроблена з  f глина, так це
виглядає так ви бачите це ви працюєте своєю
рукою, так як ми можемо перекласти це на
українську один кабінет молодець давайте
перейдемо до відділення медичної допомоги із стоматологічною
хірургією це чудово
зазвичай у нас є відділення медичного обслуговування в
школах саме це  є обов’язковим для
кожної школи, але чи є у нас стоматологічна
хірургія, не в усіх школах вона є, але
в більшості шкіл вона є, і
дуже приємно, що ви також можете піти і перевірити свої
зуби, тому давайте ще раз переглянемо, ця
школа дуже сучасна  він має
гарну зелену зону харчування, яке
забезпечує школа, добре збалансоване
та здорове, ми також маємо високотехнологічне
обладнання в школі, і у нас є
багато додаткових заходів для цього яйця,
ми організували такі місця, як
футбольний стадіон, баскетбольний майданчик,
сучасний  team studios критий басейн
і поетична студія, а також у
нас є відділення медичної допомоги з
добре зробленою стоматологічною хірургією,
тепер давайте дізнаємося більше інформації
про цю школу давайте йти це t  він
великий текст для вас, тому я даю вам дві
хвилини, щоб розглянути це, оскільки ви бачите, що у нас
є детальна інформація, тому
швидко подивіться на текст, які
назви кімнати зникне, і я маю
тут список кімнат, про який я згадував
в тексті вони правильні, добре, я даю
вам підказку, подивіться текст ще раз
протягом 5 секунд, а потім дайте мені відповідь,
щоб я показав вам текст, і вони порахували
один два три чотири п'ять, тому скажіть мені,
будь ласка, які помилки  футбольний
майданчик музичні студії басейн мистецька
студія кераміка актова зала відкритий
спортивний стадіон танцювальна студія Браво
тому у нас немає футбольного майданчика в
тексті у нас є баскетбольний майданчик і у нас
немає танцювальної студії у нас зараз є
спортзал давайте прочитаємо  текст ще раз, тож я
даю вам дві хвилини, щоб переглянути
текст
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте потроху розглянемо
баскетбольний майданчик відкритий баскетбольний
майданчик має професійне антидраматичне
покриття для активних видів спорту та зовнішніх
ігор баскетбол volle  yball badminton
та інші, тож давайте подивимося на деякі слова
тут, мені подобається слово антидраматична
поверхня, давайте запишемо це нове
слово для вас те
саме анти драматична поверхня анти
перестановка музична студія Apocrypha
давайте прочитаємо ту частину про музичну студію,
там є професійна акустична система
новітнє професійне музичне
обладнання, включаючи барабан, синтезатор
у музичній студії, шкільні музичні гурти
зможуть проводити тут свої репетиції
та проявляти креативність,
тож давайте тут знаходимо нові слова добре, мені
подобаються слова акустична система давайте
запишемо скажімо акустична система також ми  я
згадав музичне обладнання, я впевнений, що ви
знаєте слово «барабан», тож давайте з
синтезатором, давайте запишемо його ідеально,
і мені також подобається слово «репетиції», тому
перед виступом на
сцені вам потрібно провести багато
репетицій, тому репетицій  значить неодноразово
дивись давайте запишемо це також
репетиції Браво
давайте далі з басейном там
басейн 25 метрів завдовжки з 5
довжини плавання сучасний дизайн тепла
підлога і високоякісна система
підлоги Безкоштовне очищення і зробити
заняття з плавання приємними і безпечними, тому
тепла підлога і система високої якості, тож
давайте запишемо систему високої якості
добре, щоб з високоякісною системою ви могли
зробити заняття з плавання приємними і безпечними
давайте перейдемо до художньої студії світлої та
просторої нашої студії, де вивчають архітектуру
та різноманітність стилів і
технік мистецтва, тому тут мені
подобається прикметник просторий, такий величезний простір, у
вас достатньо місця, щоб практикувати та вивчати
різні техніки, тому давайте запишемо його
просторий, давайте  з поезією гончарна
майстерня допомагає розвивати
координацію дітей молодшого віку і подобається всім
вікам, вивчаючи комікси та
техніки ліплення, тому з цього речення я б
вибрав слово ki romick's Kyra mica
давайте запишемо його молодець давайте перейдемо
до монтажного отвору багатофункціональний
монтажний отвір є  Оснащена за
останнім словом техніки та професійного звукового
обладнання школа  l також
оснащений софітом і новітнім обладнанням для
проведення різноманітних подій, конференцій і
театральних постановок, тому ми можемо проводити
різні заходи на сцені.
Це підходить для всіх. Давайте йти далі
, відкритий спортивний стадіон є
п'ять бігових леїв і футбольне поле,
яке має  сучасне професійне покриття
добре зроблено, тому тут у нас є слово поверхня
, а також пам'ятайте антидраматична
поверхня тут у нас є сучасна професійна
поверхня, тому поверхня знову що
це означає Prakriti молодець, давайте закінчимо
з тренажерним залом так багатофункціональний просторий
тренажерний зал з професійним фітнес-устаткуванням
і лазіння по стінах, це також дуже
цікаво, тому ми бачимо слово просторий
просторий тренажерний зал означає, що він не крихітний,
він досить великий
для всіх,
і ви можете займатися фітнесом, а
також можете займатися лазінням по стінах. Це
цікаво, я ніколи не бачив  стіна
піднімається на неї в школах, тому це виглядає як
унікальна школа для мене, давайте переглянемо
слова ще раз  n антитравматична поверхня
акустична система репетиції
високоякісна система простора і
пірамікс молодці хлопці, це школа, яку я
знайшов тут у Києві, але це не школа, в
якій ви хочете навчатися, мабуть, тому я
хочу, щоб ви створили свою власну школу
школа вашої мрії, і це
буде ваш проект, ваше домашнє завдання, поки
ви збираєтеся думати про школу своєї мрії
або школу вашої мрії,
будь ласка, додайте важливу інформацію
загальну інформацію про шкільні
кімнати, які у вас є, це
важливо, що  чи хотіли б ви мати у
своїй школі додаткові послуги, такі як
студії віршів чи танців і, звичайно,
обладнання, яке обладнання
ви хотіли б мати у своїй школі, дозвольте мені
показати вам приклад, що я
підготував для вас, тому це державна школа  для
учнів початкової та середньої школи ця мета
– класична двоповерхова будівля у
формі квадрата школа
спеціалізується на мовах, які можна вивчати
китайською та японською  тут окрім
європейських мов
ця школа має 29 кабінетів, є
три лабораторії хімії фізики та
біології та музична студія художня студія
спортзал актова зала для постановки драматургії
бібліотека арфа та 20 аудиторій з
інших предметів є англійський
театральний клуб  яка пропонує вистави
3-4 рази на рік у школі,
учні забезпечені індивідуальними планшетами для
навчання і є дуже потужний Wi-Fi
з безкоштовним доступом для всіх, тому
це школа моєї мрії, я хотів би,
щоб ви створили свою школу  мрія і
наступний урок ми збираємося обговорити це,
тому домашнє завдання проект час моя школа мрії
вам не потрібно це малювати, просто спробуйте це
важлива інформація загальна
інформація кімнати додаткові послуги та
обладнання, тому Ізабель це означає,
що потрібно припинити урок, дякую
дуже до зустрічі наступного разу
[Музика].